queremos evaluar la integral definida
que va de 3 a 3 de la función fx de x y
nos dan la gráfica de la función fx en
donde ya es igual a fx y nos dan el área
entre fx y el eje x a lo largo de
diferentes intervalos y bueno si
analizamos esto en realidad no
necesitamos analizar la gráfica porque
en general
si tenemos la integral definida de
cualquier función fx que va de por
ejemplo de a al mismo valor a es decir
de un valor al mismo valor esto siempre
será igual a cero entonces si vamos de 3
a 3 o no se dé menos pía menos pi
siempre será igual a 0 y una forma de
verlo es que gráficamente empezamos y
nos detenemos en el mismo punto en el 3
así que en realidad no existe ninguna
área hagamos otro
ahora queremos encontrar la integral
definida que va de 7 a 4 de la función
fx de x entonces vamos de 7 a 4 ahora
tal vez piensen así el área entre
fx y el eje x es 2 entonces tal vez la
respuesta es 2 pero en realidad esta
área solo aplica cuando tenemos el valor
menor en el límite inferior y el valor
mayor en el límite superior es decir la
integral que va de 4 a 7 de la función
fx de x esta integral si es igual a 2
está integral corresponde a esta área
bajo la curva pero qué pasa con esta que
pasa cuando intercambiamos los límites y
que en lugar de ir de 4 a 7 pasamos de 7
a 4
bueno la clave aquí es que si
intercambiamos los límites
esta es una propiedad clave para las
integrales definidas
cambiamos los límites entonces
simplemente podemos escribir la integral
negativa es decir que esto es igual a
menos la integral definida que va de 4 a
7 de la función fx de x y por lo tanto
esto es igual a menos ahora sí cuál es
la integral definida de fx de x claro es
esta área y fx se encuentra por arriba
del eje x por lo tanto es un área
positiva entonces esto es igual a todos
positivo pero como tenemos el signo
negativo nuestra expresión original es
igual a menos 2